And then of course,
by the time the child is old enough to
be launched out into the social world,
then all the constraints that are
associated with the playground are
immediately placed on that child.
And that's a very unforgiving landscape,
right?
Because the last thing a child wants
really the last thing that child wants
is not to have any friends or even
perhaps equally seriously not to have a
best friend.
Huh?
Not read something so idiotic the other
day that I couldn't believe it.
So the newest prince,
so Queen Elizabeth's,
I guess great grandchild is off to
daycare and in the UK and in this
daycare,
they don't let the kids have best
friends because that's unfair.
I thought no
something times you see something that's
so stupid you can't even believe it.
It,
it,
it exists.
And that was one of those examples
because it's been known for quite a long
time,
that one of the developmental milestones
that children attain somewhere between
say the age of five and 10 is they pick
a best friend.
And so they.
And,
and you know the hypothesis well that's
unfair to all the other children.
It's like,
well,
first of all,
you can't be the best friend to everyone
because you then maybe there is a
billion children,
so each of them gets one second.
It's like that's just not a very deep
relationship,
so the idea that you can be equally
friendly with everyone is so
preposterous,
but even worse.
The thing is the thing that the child is
doing is actually becoming.
They're stepping out of their
egocentricity because they're best
friends becomes more important than they
are,
and that's a precursor for adult
relationships where you know if you're
married,
while your partner should be at least as
important as you are,
and the relationship should be more
important.
But then when you have children,
it's like they're more important than
you that that's that.
It's unless there's something wrong with
you,
you come second in.
Your children come first and they're way
first.
They're not just a little.
I mean you're necessary because without
you,
they're not going to manage,
so you have to take care of yourself,
but you're not number one anymore.
Once you have kids and less seriously,
unless you didn't learn the lessons in
the playground and when you have a best
friend,
you're not number one.
They are and so,
so anyways,
there are these constraints that emerge
in the.
In the social landscape,
you have to have friends and also you
have to single someone out as
particularly unique among those friends
and establish a genuinely reciprocal and
caring relationship.
I can't remember the psychiatrist who
studied this so intently.
Unfortunately,
he was the first person to to do a
detailed analysis of the best friend
relationships that children established.
It's,
I'd like to give him credit for his
ideas,
but unfortunately I can't remember his
name,
so.
Okay.